all right today we are back testing
camera phones once again the all-new
Google pixel 7 Pro the iPhone 14 pro Max
and the all-new xiaomi 12T Pro with the
200 megapixel sensor
who's gonna win out of this battle
royale Zachy who do you think is going
to win
a b iPhone iPhone I think it could be
the iPhone too but we're gonna find out
anyway let's get down to testing the
front facing cameras in video first okay
first we're doing the front-facing
camera here 4K 30 because the iPhone can
do 4K 24 but I think the Android phones
are only doing 4K 30 or 1080 30 for the
xiaomi anyway
let's do some video right now
talking to the uh the cameras you can
tell see stabilization hand holding it
great exposure everything is balanced
iPhone obviously does really good
front facing camera video we all know
this I don't need to do too much on this
anyway let's go to the Google pixel 7
Pro we're using the front-facing camera
here for 4k 30p on the Google pixel 7
Pro
and I gotta tell you it's looking good
Jackie this is looking really good it's
got a little more contrast than the
iPhone the iPhone's a little bit less
contrast to here but a lot of great
detail uh stabilization seems pretty
good yeah not too bad now let's go to
the xiaomi 12T here's the xiaomi 12T Pro
now of course xiaomi's only do 1080p 30
or 60p so
yeah it is what it is you don't get 4k
with the xiaomi's you've never gotten 4K
with the xiaomi's in 2022 xiaomi has yet
to give us 4K for the front-facing
camera so I mean we kind of know how
this is going to go I mean look Granite
Instagram reels Tick Tock you're not
using 4K but you can always you know
crop it if you want to it's good to have
some extra resolution but this one looks
a little bit blown out in the background
I'm not looking good on the xiaomi
this is not my best look out of the
xiaomi so it's between the iPhone and
the Google pixel 7 let us know what you
think in terms of video now we're going
to go into camera mode okay now we're
gonna do uh photos front-facing camera
photo mode here I'm using the xiaomi 12T
Pro here got the elephants in the
background look at that nice vibrant
colors a little bit contrasty sky is
blown out can't see much of the clouds
it's got a 20 megapixel sensor on this
but
does this mean it's gonna be better
you let us be the judge okay now we're
on the iPhone 14 pro Max great color
tones on the skin not Overexposed you
can still see the clouds here everything
is well balanced
yeah the elephants look great
my little green Dumbo friend here he's
probably got a different name I just
call them something else that hopefully
it's not too bad but this is Dumbo yeah
there we go sometimes it's not about the
megapixels it's about how it resolves
the image the colors the exposure all
that is important now let's go to the
Google pixel 7 Pro looking at the Google
pixel 7 Pro here more contrasty you're
going to see more detail in the shadows
with the iPhone versus the pixel 7. Pro
here but a lot of good detail you can
see the clouds good you can see my teal
Dumbo but he's now blue he's not teal so
I would say the colors are probably more
accurate out of the iPhone out than out
of the Google pixel 7 Pro but yeah
not bad but a little bit contrasty okay
now we're gonna be testing the rear
cameras for video now in front of me
I've got rajinikan we're in Little India
by the way now Zaki says he's the most
famous Bollywood actor of all time is
this true Zaki it is okay you watch
Bollywood movies yes I do all right I'll
watch some of the RR something there are
some a triple R something RR yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch that on Netflix man hey
it's pretty good the CGI and the
fighting is awesome let's get here to
the video real quick
this up here oh so nice great colors
great stability that's the main camera
go two go three rajinikan is looking
fantastic
yeah we're gonna Ultra wide as well got
this van in front of us not really
cinematic exactly but you know we're not
concentrating on the van now we go to
the pixel 7 Pro to see how good the
video is here
okay the colors are very they pop a
little bit more here more contrasting
same with the photos
it looks good
go number two
okay a little bit blurry there five
times sharpens up a bit
guy right here trying to back up into us
great for video
hey but I gotta tell you right now
looking at the blue here the blue pops
man the colors really pop on this video
for this was just more contrasty
this guy single-handedly ruined our
rajini con shots
and he keeps doing it again
whatever
but looking at the uh the trees right
here the greens are really prominent
very saturated a little bit more
saturated than what you would normally
get
now here's the thing with the xiaomi
though
unlike these other two that only do 4K
the xiaomi does 8K video
Jackie I'm gonna break your computer
with this file real quick
you ready
8K video with rajini Khan
why is it all the trucks keep coming to
us when we're shooting can you explain
this to me pull this inzaki I mean I
know we had a little bit of budget for
the shoot but bring these guys in 8k 24p
you can record up to six minutes in AK
I guess the phone overheats I don't know
or maybe it's just storage
let's zoom in
wow
look at that that's 8K baby
go all the way back
all right
and just to play fair because no other
phone has AK except the xiaomi
we're gonna go into 4K
but 4K only does 30 and 60 like the
pixel 7.
there it is
and go back
so now we're going to go into cinematic
mode now the xiaomi doesn't have
cinematic mode but the pixel 7 Pro does
and so does the iPhone let's see who has
the better cinematic mode in 4k
well exactly it's not every day we see
a famous celebrity here in Singapore Mr
Stark himself hey Tony you mind if I
take a photo how about I do cinematic
mode with Iron Man what do you think
yeah you know what that car is dope
I would bet
this is 4K
go back
the Iron Man
because the xiaomi does a new cinematic
mode it's between
the iPhone and the pixel oh interesting
I gotta correct myself the pixel 7 Pro
does not do 4K cinematic mode it only
does HD doesn't matter we're gonna try
it anyway
[Music]
guys something interesting about the
Cinematic mode on the iPhone 14 that
I've noticed this year especially maybe
it's the 4K or whatever but the focusing
doesn't stick on as well as it did on
the previous generation for some reason
maybe it's because it's in 4k Now versus
1080 but I realize that it does lose
focus
whereas the pixel 7 Pro does a really
good job of staying on what you want it
to be on focus without having you having
to tap on the screen so perhaps someone
will be an update that Apple can address
in the near future but I will say in
terms of the quality you guys be the
judge but these are really neck and neck
I think both of them do a fantastic job
but of course the iPhone does 4K 24p now
and the pixel 7 Pro only does 1080. so
yeah but I would say in terms of the
color in terms of the look
I kind of prefer the pixel 7 Pro
cinematic book
and that shocked me because I really
like the iPhones but
Google does a really good job anyway
let's take some more photos
trying out portrait mode on the iPhone
an interesting concept here the portrait
mode is more enhanced on the iPhone and
of course you can adjust it down it does
look a little bit more like you have a
longer focal length lens versus the
pixel 7 which is not as prominent
so between the portrait modes on this
even at F9 on the iPhone versus whatever
it is here on the uh on the pixel 7. I
think I gotta hand it
to the iPhone what do you guys think
we'll put it up in post yeah yeah put it
on post you can't see [ __ ] here
what do you guys think look at it and
we'll put up here on the screen you let
us know what you guys think but I would
tell you I think the iPhone wins in this
regard 50 megapixels 48
obviously 12 megapixel images but I
think the Apple's really improved on the
portrait mode versus the pixel should I
try the xiaomi what do you think I can
give it a shot just give it a shot I
don't have a lot of faith in the xiaomi
for this portion of it but you never
know I could be surprised this could be
the sleeper hit
oh Jackie I'm a little surprised look at
the foreground blur and the background
blur
that's looking legit
I'm gonna rank it this way
iPhone 14 pro Max
xiaomi 12T Pro and the Google pixel 7
Pro
what do you guys think we're gonna put
the images here on the screen let us
know what you think you know exactly
this is a photo this is one of those
street photography photos that we should
get right okay what I'm gonna do with
this image real quick here right because
we have a 200 megapixel sensor in this
now to get to the 200 megapixel sensor
it's a little bit tricky on the xiaomi
got to go to more Ultra HD then you
gotta tap on the 200 megapixel so you
have to do a three-step process get to
get to 200 megapixels but
we're here we're gonna do it
there's a lot of detail a lot of detail
I gotta say the right away the iPhone
has the more natural natural colors out
of all the out of all these phones
with the pixel 7 Pro it's changing the
actual the tone of the blue slightly to
being a little bit more of a royal blue
versus this sort of uh sky blue so
I'm noticing that with some of the
colors it's not as true
to what your eye sees again everybody
post edits they post process you can
always fix it but it's just something to
take note of okay let's head to the
temple
as we're walking to the temple here's a
message from our sponsor MSI this video
is brought to you by MSI meet the summit
E6 then flip featuring the latest 12th
gen Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30
series graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD
Plus touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
okay now we're going to capture the
architecture of this beautiful Temple
here in Little India by seeing what the
zoom capabilities are on these cameras
so we're gonna travel with the iPhone 14
pro Max here now this goes to three
times and of course then you can go to
digital I think a little bit more than
that but we're going to go to three
times here see what it's like because it
crops into the sense that they say
great exposure on the clouds can see the
clouds beautifully I'm going to zoom in
even more digital Zoom not bad
a little post-processing happening
coming into play when you zoom in
maximum but it looks good Valiant effort
by the iPhone 14 pro Max let's go to the
Google pixel 7 Pro here now this does
five times you know one thing I like
about
the pixel 7 Pro here is you've got this
leveler here on the screen which is nice
because I always take my images on an
angle for some reason I always have to
corrected light bro oh not bad this is
impressive up to 30 times and the image
has got a lot of detail yeah it's a
little bit pixelated this is definitely
usable I would use this now we go
to the xiaomi go two times
does it go further
it does
not as far as the other ones though it
only goes into 10 times
yeah unfortunately the xiaomi loses this
battle I would say in terms of reach
and resolving power
I got to give it to the pixel 7 Pro on
this iPhone comes in a close second but
the iPhone image looks a little bit more
natural than the others do I mean I
think it's kind of neck and neck between
Google and apple but the xiaomi nah all
right but here's the question right yeah
if it's 200 megapixels
why don't you just use the main camera
and then like crop it and post why don't
we try it right now I like exactly when
you come with these good ideas like this
never listen to anyone that says you're
not the brightest bulb on the chandelier
let's try 200 megapixels
and go now with zacky's magic he's going
to crop in and show you what it looks
like
10 times 30 times Zoom with 200
megapixels and see which camera is the
best one but I'm going to tell you I
think personally
the pixel 7 has it
but this is very impressive with the
detail that we're getting out of
tournament fixes a lot of pixel mini
happening here but it's pretty
impressive anyway let's move on to some
other photos
with
what should we do next Zach who do you
think we should do this
canoe people we're going to shoot people
all right so next we're going to shoot
some photos of people
and see how it captures the face the
skin texture
and the colors because that's the most
important because when you're with
somebody you always got to get a nice
photo out of them right you guys know
you have to be the Instagram boyfriend
you better get the right phone for it
otherwise you're on the couch
can I take a photo damn thank you
yo Zach I'm gonna take a photo of you
yeah
we're gonna find the right glasses for
you
that's you
[Music]
Fuller science and the xiaomi is
interesting it's like Overexposed over
saturated it's a look I won't say it's
bad because it kind of reminds me a
little bit of film in a way
but it's a look and you may not like
this look it's really a lot of
processing happening here now when I'm
looking at
the pixel 7 Pro
it does a really good job in terms of
portrait with person skin tone looks
great there's a little bit more contrast
as we've been talking about in this
video but it looks good the iPhone does
a really good job of exposing the entire
scene well
but when you're using let's say a
professional camera like Zach is using
the z62 for example right here and he's
recording me
you're not going to get that that phone
look where everything's exposed
correctly you're going to get your
subjects exposed in the background it's
going to be a little bit blur exactly
don't fall he's going down the steps
here I think to me in that scenario
right there that the pixel 7 Pro looked
more natural like a professional
mirrorless camera
okay minus the contrasty look to it
which I don't prefer I prefer the
iPhones way that it's a little bit less
on the contrast a little more Shadows
are developed on this but overall I
would say
I like how the pixel 7 rendered that
image better anyway that's just me let
me know what you guys think anyway Zachy
uh let's walk around take some more
photos here a little India and then
we'll come back with my final thoughts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guys as you saw from the sample images
there in the Montage I mean all these
phones have their pros and cons right I
mean the 200 megapixel sensor from the
xiaomi it's nice it's kind of a first of
its kind I believe other cameras
manufacturers will come out with it soon
but
I just feel that it's not the par with
as well as Ultra of course that's a like
a collaboration so those cameras will be
a lot better but it pales in comparison
to the iPhone and the pixel 7 Pro but
between the pixel 7 Pro and the iPhone
14 pro Max I'm gonna have to agree with
Zaki on this I think the iPhone is a
complete package in terms of video and
in terms of Photography the pixel 7 Pro
has some really strong points but it
also has some weak points as well and I
think it has to do with Android versus
iOS anyway those are my thoughts I'd
love to hear from you guys let us know
in the comment section below which phone
you think is better and if you like this
camera review check out our other camera
reviews right here